[Music]
hey guys welcome to vlogmas day 46 47 3
I don't know um just it's all blending
together it's going so fast you guys oh
my god it's almost like half way it
started and done and oh my god I have
like no makeup on my face I'm so sorry
that you guys have to deal with this
this is like so disgusting like
literally I mean just try to ignore it
um anyway so it's like 8:20 p.m. I
started my day like super late I was
just up last night like editing vlogs
and like working and just like hating
myself and then editing more vlogs for
you guys I've had like a really
productive day so far just like lots of
like self-loathing which I got all the
way early and have like continued
throughout the day wearing it like
starting with the day and um just start
to like do some stuff and then you guys
are gonna um come with me and I have
like so much stuff to get done today so
it's gonna be like a really productive
day so um yeah oh my god my dishes are
like so dirty and I hate them I'm so
sorry you guys literally like so sorry
you don't deserve this and like it what
is that and we have goose here hi goose
are you loving vlogmas so far goose look
in her tail oh my god it's like she's a
dog oh my god you're just like such a
dog sometimes like you're wagging your
tail like like it's a sign of your
emotional state because you can't speak
because you're like a dog um oh my god
focus on my face thank you god I'm so
sorry
so my living room I mean oh my god this
isn't my living room was such a idiot
it's my dining room it's just been like
super crazy dirty and messy because I'm
just kind of like
complete mass so I'm just gonna like
clean it before I cuz it just like makes
me feel better you should watch this
[Music]
whereas in focus focus oh my god you're
such a stupid piece of [ __ ]
this camera sucks too
um so like I said um I have like a super
busy day today I'm just like so many
things that I have to do unlike so many
um things so um yeah um I didn't like
sleep really well last night so I I like
open up so much on here I'm sorry you
guys it's just like vlog minutes I feel
like I can be more personal with you
guys so like let's just get this busy
day started I love that song isn't that
a song I don't know oh my god I go off
on so many tangents sorry guys seriously
let's get this day started oh my god
you're like such a dog oh my god I just
like changed the framing of my video and
it's like so different I can look at
more of my face now and it's so ugly oh
my god I'm sorry guys like you shouldn't
even have to deal with this like these
videos are completely free for you and
you have complete free will to like look
at other stuff anywhere all the time and
like the fact that my face looks like
this it's just like I'm so sorry oh my
god it's so much better
ah sorry I even had to do what that like
so I'm just like editing like a time cuz
like I'm so busy and so I just thought
I'd show it to you for a second it like
wow together this is like I'm gonna show
you just like how I add it so like okay
can you see that that that's all you got
um also I just realized that I've been
buying like so many holiday gifts that I
thought I would do like a quick haul for
you guys
so my god this angle is like so bad but
you know whatever I'm I put it all out
there for you guys okay um so um this is
a I'm gonna get a text sorry to rub just
like.how superiorly a popular man and
your face this is a bag that made up
then and I got it from Target with like
a thousand other at the same back it's
like it oh my god what is wrong with my
face focus oh my god the focus okay so I
just got back from taking goose for a
walk
who are you what are you honey oh my god
my dog is like has the best sense of
humor of all dogs look at that oh my god
oh my god are you seeing them like she
just does this I don't even like tell
her to like where does she get it from
oh my god so he just went for a walk and
like I forgot my vlogging camera cuz I'm
an idiot
so I can't do anything right um but I
did have my phone with me and I managed
to capture this like super super cute
moment so I'll insert that footage here
what is she even doing like so like I
don't get it and it's the only focus for
me if you like stop um so just been like
super busy day like it's such a busy day
you guys it's crazy and like sometimes I
just get so lost but it's all good it's
like it's positive good busy like I'm
really happy that I'm busy but it's just
like the busiest day second same
seriously like me face needs a new face
yeah oh my god I love this don't you
why so few are gone so I'm headed to
target because I have to everyday or
I'll die but I'm going to target to just
like touch stuff and then I'm going to
like I need like um to touch stuff I
also need to cook some food for dinner
cuz I've been like super into cooking
lately so I haven't been like really
this guy looks so weird and like make me
different than you but I've been like
super craving spaghetti squash so I'm
just like hoping this target has it
[Music]
didn't work
[Music]
oh my god okay so I'm Matt from Target
classically I got like so much more than
they should have because if I don't I'll
like die um the spaghetti squash however
I had to get at like a grocery store or
Target and have it which just you know
it goes to show that there's like no God
um but it's fine never I are excited
carry these all up my front steps
without like any help which is also like
just a double confirmation that there's
no God um but I want to show you guys
I'm gonna make dinner for myself a
little bit and go for a jog um it's like
quarter to 11:00 p.m. so it's like Magic
Hour
but I got this Perkis I'm whispering
because I think she's evolving to like
be able to understand English and I
don't want her to know yet this was in
the Christmas section of toys for dogs
and it makes me go like Dutch why is
this owl that is truly overcompensating
in news clothing choices part of
Christmas so let's give it to her let's
take the tag off first okay check it has
another one my god sucks
okay got it hey good thank this is for
you
this stupid how is for you you honey
you ready do you really good girl yeah
good girl oh my god you're like such a
dog ah so stupid okay so I'm gonna get
the spaghetti squash in the oven and
make dinner and like I'll show you guys
in a little bit it's just like you know
the business damn day of my entire life
so oh my face no like foot but also
focus on it oh my god um so I just got
done
and um we're so light oh my god there it
is I'm screwed I'm running everyone
probably like like a million miles but
you know it's like not my best but I'm
here to be real with you so um my okay
sauce is done in the oven let's look at
it ah so I just put some of my dishes in
the dishwasher because I started to wash
some of them and then I just like hated
it so much and like dishes are kind of
like scary you know like they might be
legitimately literally like the scariest
thing I've ever experienced in my life
because they're like you know like they
get dirty and you know how they get
dirty but then like you don't know where
all the dirt came from sometimes you
just see like color so on them that
you're like that I didn't put that there
so it's just like scary we're gonna make
dinner it's one of my favorite meals I
think I haven't actually tried it before
I don't think so I forget a lot um we're
gonna make a my dinner so here I'm gonna
show you how to do it so basically you
just take like all of this and then you
basically just like turn it into that
okay so I just like ate all my food so
legitimately fast like seriously I
realize that you guys probably wonder
like what I got from Target so let me
show you some of the things I got at
Target two of these look like chest hair
I got all kinds of stuff for my that's
um 2016 these oh my god this oak dish
because like thanks so you get it okay
done oh my god
yes things have taken a turn I put some
Biore Pore strips on my face and
sometimes I put one on my chin it's not
even sticking I hate it
today was just like the busiest day ever
guys um I'm getting ready for bed now
and like oh my god she thinks she's
people but I realized that I didn't get
to say goodbye I feel like I didn't vlog
a lot today like I know I'm I'm like the
worst vlogger ever um and so like I'm
super sorry that there's not like a ton
of footage for you today just you know
one of those like super busy days where
I didn't get to pull out my camera
because like sometimes I was um like
peeing or like standing by myself in my
house so you know you got it
um so yeah that's gonna be it for today
um am I gonna Toys R Us to my advent
calendar oh my god I totally forget
again advent calendar oh my god I'm such
an idiot to think that I would have
enjoyment doing an advent calendar but
like you know so um I hope you guys
enjoyed this he did give it a like don't
forget to subscribe and um yeah um I'm
just like there's so much dude I'm just
like spacing so much ah these nails
oh and if you are living in Australia
please buy a ticket to our nofilter show
comedy tour that we are doing down there
next week which is crazy and if you
aren't a fashion and sound beautiful
like I mean this is very stylish I wrote
a style guide called grace and style the
art of pretending you have it it's
available for pre-sale at grey style
book calm and I would love if you
pre-ordered it because like I'm not
afraid to like just be me I don't know
yeah I like the way I said that home I'm
Trever time
I don't know let me try one more time
because it's like I don't know and I
love you I love you I love you guys like
you don't know the depths of my love
like I love you as much as I hate myself
and I love you and I love you okay today
say it enough